[Musique]
la salle jean 66 ans candidat du parti
résistants c'est votre deuxième campagne
présidentielle bonjour et bienvenue jean
lassalle bonjour sharks patrick roy pour
déterrer vos racines il nous faut partir
en altitude tout près de la frontière
espagnole
avant d'être un homme politique est
d'abord un paysage celui de votre valley
la vallée d'aspe les dans tous les pores
de votre poids de vous constituer l vous
détermine c'est une vallée des pyrénées
en béarn votre village s'appelle
lourdios ichère 136 âmes aujourd'hui et
tous les ans un rituel la fête de la
transhumance la montée des troupeaux
dans les hauteurs c'est un reportage de
99 vous voir avec votre béret faisait
déjà le maire de ce village
la transhumance une activité importante
en béarn 150 berger gagne les estives il
représente environ 450 éleveurs pour un
cheptel de près de 70 brebis et un
millier de vaches rassemblés à l'entrée
du village les touristes mais aussi les
habitants de la vallée sont venus
partager l'événement les troupeaux sont
marqués avant de gagner la montagne 90%
des actifs de lourdios cent des bergers
au des pasteurs étrangers morts en tout
cas et nous avons encore trente
exploitations agricoles qui sont occupés
d'un truc qui ne proposait un ordinaire
et puis comme vous le voyez
l'ensemble des prairies deschamps sont
entretenus je dirais presque jardiner ça
a bougé depuis
est ce que ça change vous me parlez jeu
j'étais en train de me retrouver et
oui parce que malheureusement nous avons
perdu
beaucoup de bras exane a fini par nous
certaines aussi avec un peu plus de
retard qu'ailleurs il y a un petit peu
plus de de rance et d'arbres qui ont
poussé mais malgré tout
c'est pas mal par rapport au reste du
territoire français qui nous ressemble
autre tradition le champ qui est aussi
un mode d'expression beaucoup de choses
se disent en chansons chez vous jean
lassalle alors en voici une la rencontre
d'un berger et d'une bergère chantée par
la chorale de laruns dans les pyrénées
atlantiques c'est une archive de 1969
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
est
le
soleil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre langue maternelle est le berner
petit vous apprenait ensuite l'espagnol
et enfin le français il paraît qu'à
votre entrée à l'école votre première
institutrice ne vous comprends pas ray
c'est vrai et elle allait souvent
consulté la voisine marguerite faut
essayer de décrypter mais un homme a
topé
d'ailleurs le premier jour est là m'a
appelé auprès des ailes au bureau et
elle m'a dit vas t'asseoir soir j'avais
entendu parler je me suis dis attention
à ce soir et j'ai passé la journée morts
de peur alors que je le craignais rien
le français est donc votre troisième
langue est-ce que vous vous sentez
pleinement français ah oui mais ça je
les ai ressenti je te dire pratiquement
dès mes premières sensations de deux
devis à ce beau monde il faut dire que
papa est très profonde et bars
république est profondément gaulliste
maison que les méthodes des deux cooptés
parce que du côté de papa tout le monde
était gaulliste du côté de maman il n'y
avait que des filles dont l'une par
bonheur d'être l'épousé papa les autres
avaient été posées des réfugiés
espagnols
donc c'était des histoires de de
résistance mais ils étaient tous
profondément républicaines voyons à
présent jean lassalle vos débuts en
politique rubrique big bang
[Musique]
votre première apparition à la
télévision comme un politique c'est en
88 33 ans mère déjà depuis 12 ans on
vous retrouve à bordeaux pour
l'inauguration du nouvel hôtel de région
nous bien entendu le lustre la richesse
pour nous elles se situent surtout en
termes de subsistance dont nous
attendons effectivement beaucoup de la
région et qu'elle soit un guide qu'elle
soit
une instance qui lance les programmes et
qui nous aident à maintenir la vie dans
notre montagne dans nos villages vous
parlez de subsistance de survie pour
votre vallée votre engagement politique
il y a de la défense de cette terre oui
mais sympathique rhin vont nous prenait
aux tripes parce que je savais pas que
ziva j'existe et opaques les premières
vous avez vu que vous m'avez laissé sans
voix et au fond je retrouve ce qui a été
le fil conducteur de ma vie oui une
forme de résistance pour maintenir ce
que je croyais essentiel le combat il a
été gagnée ou perdue depuis
et c'est mitigé disant que nous l'avons
un peu moins perdu qu'ailleurs mais nous
sommes quand même très touché mais quand
on regarde les vallées pyrénéennes
notamment de l'ouest on constate que le
fromage que je vois actuellement sur les
yeux
les veaux sous la mère les anions
le noeud
le coopérative puis une femme
d'industrie encore relativement bien
d'adapter ont fait que nous avons plutôt
bien tiré notre épingle du jeu mais nous
avons perdu beaucoup beaucoup de monde
dans les vallées en 2002 vous voici élu
député et le soir de votre victoire vous
avez des mots pour votre adversaire des
mots rares en politique
je pensais que ce serait beaucoup plus
serrés que ceux ci a mérité et j'ai une
pensée pour mon adversaire malheureux
face aux médias
je veux simplement venir dire à tous
ceux qui nous écoutent que je crois que
nous avons livré un beau combat pourquoi
ce souci du concurrent battu parce que
toute la journée dans les jours qui ont
possédé
jonchier dans une chaussette et que nous
étions très proches ils avaient le vent
en poupe ils devaient gagner et je me
disais bon comment je vais le vivre s'il
gagne et ça y est je vais te déjà fait à
l'idée et je me disais lui est certaine
de gagner si le père et le vivra très
douloureusement nous venions de nous
livrer un combat sans merci
comme deux fleuves donc forcément
voilà c'est sur ça que je pense et j'ai
d'ailleurs passé toute la nuit et à vrai
dire vous entrez donc à l'assemblée
nationale et c'est le début d'une longue
série de comment dire de performance ou
de coups d'éclat
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous
pouvez vous asseoir et ne pas chanter
danser des musiques asseyez vous asseyez
vous
asseyez vous
monsieur comment il s'appelle
quazar asseyez-vous
ce qui est honteux c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de faire monsieur là ça
vous n'avez pas à vous lever et à hurler
dans l'assemblée le béarnais privé de
micro s'est mise en colère pour faire
entendre son avis il ya ici 50 députés
qui ne servent à rien c'est honteux vous
poussez un vieux ça va venir tester s'il
vous plaît calmez vous vêtir à salbris
et immédiatement retirer ce gilet
parfait monsieur la salle ce rappel au
règlement sera évidemment inscrits au
procès verbal et vous en subirez les
conséquences
retirer s'il vous plaît ce gilet
sur la salle
depuis 16 jours le député udf des
pyrénées atlantiques ne quitte plus ce
canapé de la salle des quatre colonnes
une grève de la faim ses larmes ultime
qui l'a choisi pour protester contre la
délocalisation d'une usine japonaise
implanté dans sa circonscription 150
emplois sont menacés
son état devient critique au bout de 37
jours il a déjà perdu 21 kg
mais il refuse de parler de victoire
mais au bout de trente neuf jours de
grève de la faim jean lassalle a obtenu
ce qu'il voulait il vient de signer un
accord avec total et pour dire la vérité
je croyais pas jean lassalle a remisé
son béret ses chaussures de marche lui
qui était parti il y a huit mois au
chevet des français revient les jambes
lourdes des 6000 kilomètres parcourus
mais surtout l'esprit marquée par la
colère du pays
une profonde votre politique jean
lassalle c'est celle des coups d'éclat
non je n'aimais pas ça mais des
circonstances ont voulu que je n'ai
jamais pu m'exprimer
normalement
c'est un peu ma faute
j'ai suivis très longtemps françois
bayrou
qui est dedans j'ai beaucoup appris qui
a peut-être un peu a pris deux mois mais
il était promis d'accorder ce n'est que
lorsque j'ai compris que
nous disions nam chose même ne faisait
absolument plus du tout la même chose
qu'eux ils n'avaient pas compris que
nous étions en train de perdre une
nouvelle bataille décisive celle
que gagnaient la financiarisation croisé
à outrance dans le monde entier que je
les ai quittés et si vous être ça qui a
fait que j'étais un peu en décalage
sinon je n'ai pas pu supporter certain
nombre de décisions très symbolique de
ces vingt dernières années et chaque
fois je me suis levé je me suis levé
lorsque
on ferme et on m'a empêché de maintenir
une gendarmerie et d'ouvrir une centres
de secours alors ce que je venais de
finir le tunnel le plus long d'europe
sont pas huit et vingt six ans les deux
tunnels des alpes avait brûlé l'année
auparavant mme le mot sony et le
mont-blanc 400 morts je ne voulais pas
la honte sur le fond de mes fils j'ai
fait la grève de la faim omar ou totale
qu'il n'avait rien fait la note
département
m'arracher une egypte qui avait été
chercher au japon et nous en perdions
400 mis la france à la même époque je
l'avais dit à jacques chirac à plusieurs
reprises jeudi se relèvera pas j'ai
marché
quand j'ai compris que nous étions en
train de nom
d'éclater c'est ce vieux peuple
souverain s'était déclaré sûr et était
en train de devenir un addendum ces deux
femmes courant dans tous les sens après
le passage d'un tsunami et j'ai mis ce
gilet jaune lorsque j'ai compris que
tous les députés devraient être sur les
ronds-points parce que ce vieux peuple
avait trouvé le moyen de faire de dire
plus ainsi moins sur nos conditions de
vie que nous ne l'avions fait durant 30
ans ce sont donc les circonstances qui
vous ont conduit à ces coups d'éclat la
rubrique suivante va nous ramener à un
homme que vous venez de citer
vous dites souvent que vous admirez que
votre père mais vous avez eu un mentor
en politique un béarnais comme vous
françois bayrou vous adhérez à l'udf
avec lui vous êtes sur sa liste aux
européennes en 99 et par la suite vous
le suivez dans l' aventure du modem un
compagnon de route un ami avec qui vous
festoyer et vous chanter jusqu'à ce que
la politique vous sépare
tard dans la nuit dans un petit village
aux sommets des pyrénées françois bayrou
est allé fêter la victoire avec son ami
de toujours jean lassalle également élu
dans la 4e circonscription qu'en pense
votre ami de quarante ans françois
bayrou de cette candidature
c'est parce qu'il n'est pas très très
content mais c'est mon tour c'est une
période difficile entre vous il ya une
incompréhension non je ne dirais pas ça
il y a dix ans à ce qui me concerne une
émancipation
est aujourd'hui toujours brouillé
oui humainement nous aurions été
capables de vivre l'enterrement
l'enterrement de l'ancien président de
la fédération française de rugby
monsieur camon à l'église saint jean
pied de port deux heures assis côte à
côte ça a échangé un mot au moment de la
communion recevait chez nous c'est qu'à
un moment important
normalement lorsque deux frères commune
i faut qu'ils se parlent au moins est
absent devant le préfet j'ai dit assez
haut et ça m'a étonné parce que le point
c'est pas comme ils l'ont su ont repris
cette phase pardonne nous nos offenses
comme nous pardonnons aussi à ceux qui
nous ont offensés
s'affiche sur vire un peu le préfet et
nous en sommes là voyez vous c'est à
dire pas très loin
nous allons à présent vous confronter un
grand homme et même un peu plus grand
que vous par la taille
[Musique]
le général de gaulle souvent invoqué
dans cette campagne nous avons choisi
pour vous un extrait d'une émission de
65 ou de gaulle parle d'agriculture et
d'industrialisation de la france
au point de vue national à cause de
l'industrialisation problème une monde
puisqu'il s'agit d'un transfert colossal
de population de notre agriculture and
hate industrie ce transfert
naturellement on peut le trouver
regrettable
on peut en avoir du chagrin vous pensez
bien qu'un homme de mon âge qu'il très
longtemps dans sa vie a été un soldat
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui savait
c'est ce que la france a tiré depuis
toujours et en particulier pour sa
défense de ces paysans il est certain
qu'il ya là une transformation une
évolution qui est à beaucoup d'égards
attristante
mais c'est comme ça
il avait raison
mais j'avais pas vu ces images cher
patrick
encore une fois il est d'une grande
lucidité
peut-être le regret que j'ai si
longtemps après l'écoutant avec autant
de lucidité
c'est qu'il n'ait pas essayé je pensais
qu'il avait essayé d'inverser un peu le
cours de l'histoire disons qu'il me
déçoit à peine un petit peu sur ce
magnifique
passage de l'explication de l'histoire
du 20e siècle en france
voici à présent la rubrique des
changements ou des métamorphoses
[Musique]
180° parce qu'il n'est pas facile de
situer vos positions voté au centre
droit avec françois bayrou et puis votre
position sur l'europe est devenue moins
clair vous avez voté contre le mariage
pour tous contre la pma vous avez revêtu
un gilet jaune on l'a vu et vous êtes
allés aussi soutenir le mouvement
d'extrême gauche nuit debout
plus qu'un mouvement c'est un petit
village de la contestation avec son
concert forcément gratuit et sa cantine
à prix libre à l'agenda de ce qu'ils
veulent mais aussi d'une certaine
conception des choses de cardozo fait on
les gens sont pas forcément on est
obligé de donner quoi c'est mieux mais
voilà ça on attribuera aux choses a pris
aux choses ils ont voulu inscrire l'état
d'urgence dans les constitutions c'est à
dire qu'ils sont en train de mettre en
place tous les outils du fascisme je
dirais beaucoup de rage mais aussi une
bonne dose d'utopie avec le mauvais
temps le rassemblement fait un peu
réunion de famille d'extrême gauche et
c'est tout le problème qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait quand je suis rentré chez moi
j'ai demandé à mes potes nous dit-on
devenir erreur je devrais demander à mes
voisins nos militants de venir devraient
demander à mes amis de la famille c'est
peut-être qu'ils votent pas comme
l'allègement si on a du mal à vous
suivre jean lassalle centre droite
gauche où êtes vous y at il un la salle
isme
oui excusez moi je me suis suffisamment
musclée cheville pour pouvoir vous
répondre mais venant l'exemple précédent
le général de gaulle est ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'il a été un peu difficile
à suivre lui aussi parfois aller le josé
compris regardez ce qui s'en est suivie
dans les quatre ans qui ont
suivi d'affaires regardez
le de vol du second mandat et regardez
ameutant le fait qu'il a été
il a pu tenir le conseil national de la
résistance avec le parti communiste avec
l'ensemble des partis qui avaient
participé à
la résistance qu'il a été très proche du
maréchal pétain avec qui il s'était
ensuite brouillé à tout jamais le marché
le pétain qui a été enfermé à vallée
d'aspe dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
fort du portalet tout comme il avait été
enfermé dans l'allier et toute l'équipe
de vin qu est ce que vous pensez qu'il
était facile à suivre je crois qu'un
homme qui a l'intuition
qui aime passionnément ce pays et qui le
sang et conduit à avoir des attitudes et
des rencontres successives et c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui avec
résistants j'ai voulu me mettre en
position de rassembler ce grand pays ça
ne durera pas longtemps mais nous avons
besoin de le faire car vous voyez le
monde tragique dans lequel nous vivons
je le décris depuis 30 ans depuis 30 ans
seulement deux mois comment s'est moqué
de lui peut-être que maintenant on
n'acceptera pour mes dernières sorties
de bien vouloir lire un peu ce que
j'écrivais il ya déjà trente ans et qui
n'est pas tellement différent de ce qui
se passe et résistant c'est un vrai
parti avec des locaux des militants d là
sa liste oui et je dirais beaucoup
l'abstention 10 voyez vous c'est à dire
des hommes et les femmes qui ont voté
passionnément pour les plus anciens
il ya beaucoup de d'hommes et de femmes
de gauche
qui ont été résolus 20
socialiste mais plutôt à gauche voyez il
ya quelques jours elle a menti sts il ya
des communistes il ya des gaullistes et
incontestable en fait ce qu'un petit
cervin mille sympathisants et débile
adhérents en quatre ans c'est pas non
plus le perron mais oui il ya quelque
chose de sa rubrique suivante
[Musique]
le zéro pointé nous l'adressant conduite
des hommes vis-à-vis des femmes et
singulièrement dans le monde politique
en 2017 l'assemblée nationale lance une
campagne de prévention contre le
harcèlement sexuel et c'est vers vous
entre autres que les caméras et micros
se tourne
nul n'est censé ignorer la loi et
surtout pas les députés pourtant
aujourd'hui placardées dans les
ascenseurs de l'assemblée ces
affichettes reproduisent en deux
articles du code pénal sur le
harcèlement sexuel et moral un rappel
qui intervient alors que plusieurs
signalements sont en cours à l'assemblée
depuis plusieurs semaines les
témoignages d'assistante parlementaire
affluent l'un de ces députés incriminés
juge malgré tout cette campagne
d'affichage assez inutile le coma qui a
été engagé par les femmes j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire je n'ai pas cette
attitude mais
est naturel et légitime
c'est pas la peine maintenant tu joues
un domaine de l'eau à mettre partout de
placards et partout des anciennes
attachées parlementaires des élus une
journaliste vous ont accusé d'agression
sexuelle et de harcèlement aucune
plainte n'a été déposée contre vous
cependant est-ce que vous reconnaissez
avoir eu des comportements inappropriés
non je cracherais pas vous dire comme à
beaucoup cassé les couilles avec ça
et j'en ai vomi de la bile ce qui ne
m'était jamais arrivé j'avais élus sur
napoléon et vomit de la bile lorsqu'il
avait appris la déroute de soult g al
sultan espagne jamais je n'aurais cru
que la faire comme ça a pu m'arriver
je n'ai jamais fait ça j'ai beaucoup
aimé les femmes lesieu juste sorti de ma
timidité mais je tiens g a rappelé que
j'avais une légitime parisienne en
génération de parisiens suivant qui a
fait 4 vos enfants à lourdios-ichère
que j'aime passionnément
ensuite il n'ya que de sexe fort
heureusement quand je l'avais dit une
fois
je n'avais jamais compris mon père m'a
jamais appris que les gars
pour une femme lui tenir la porte lui
faire un compliment était quelque chose
de répréhensible
je les ai appris après coup il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'hommes qui réagit lorsque des
femmes étaient maltraités moi je les
fais par deux fois une fois lorsqu'une
femme est aussi j'ai pris en stop une
femme qui venait d'être violée alors que
150 voitures et peu dépassée devant moi
et elle ralentissait accélérer quand des
loyers sa robe blanche maculée de sang
et une autre fois dans le taxi parce que
j'ai mis un coup de boule à
des petits rester par terre parce qu'il
en faisait trop non j'ai jamais et
commence une discussion avec une femme à
la prenant par les fesses
et si ça avait été le cas je pense que
vu l'immense mobilisation qu'il ya eu
autour de ça et ça serait bien de
trouver une vous retrouvez les preuves
et la lire et donc le mouvement mito et
les campagnes contre le harcèlement vous
semble légitime salutaire ou ou excessif
à
son légitime et salutaire
et je
je crois trop
à la nature humaine je crois trop en la
complémentarité entre les hommes les
femmes je vois dans le visage d'une
femme à la fois maman que j'ai tenté
mais mes soeurs ma fille alizay mes
grands mères
quand vous voulez vous que ça ne soit
pas important pour moi
je sais ce qu'elles ont subi je sais ce
qu'elle suivit c'est un cas notamment en
afrique
avec des salopards qui mériteraient être
beaucoup plus poursuivi je pense
notamment à nano mais bolloré auquel
vous intéressait aussi et jose en
félicite mais pourquoi
s'acharner sur moi pourquoi avoir essayé
et le malheureux parisien a cru bon de
rappeler de susciter et dès que j'étais
quelqu'un qui était torch est au rouge
tous les jours ou alors comme on l'avait
fait assez sympathiquement quelques-uns
de mes copains mais modem si je me suis
allé que j'étais un psychopathe très
intelligent mais très dangereux capable
de viol ou de meurtre en série que
pendant 33 ans avait réussi à me
contrôler et de la partir de rien ne
garantissait plus rien non j'ai trop de
respect pour la condition humaine pour
les femmes pour me permettre de tels
agissements ce qui ne m'empêche pas
d'avoir pour elle une certaine
fascination parce que j'aime ce qui est
beau quelles que soient les âges
j'aime la vie j'ai toujours été aimait
la vie et je suis du pays de willian je
suis une pays de desproges je suis le
pays de coluche je suis de ce pays où ma
foi on a toujours eu un certain art de
vivre sans faire du mal et je défendrai
les femmes elles auraient massy patient
jusqu'à la dernière goutte de mon sang
une madeleine à présent choisi pour vous
mais ce n'est pas une femme
[Musique]
vous nous direz si cette madeleine vous
correspondent un personnage du théâtre
classique qu'il ya quelque chose d'à la
fois excessif une soif d'idéal de la
bravoure et du panache vous avez année
reg ans
c'est tout mais non c'est un peu court
jeune homme on pouvait dire dieu bien
des choses simples en variant le ton
par exemple
agressif moi monsieur si jamais un tel
nom il ferait sur le changement [ __ ]
habib khan mais il doit tremper dans
votre tasse pour voir fait vous
fabriquez à annappes
descriptif c'est un roc de trafic c'est
un cap que 10 c'est un cap c'est une
place et
la fameuse tirade du nez de cyrano
incarné ici par jean piat quelque chose
en commun avec ce personnage jean
lassalle et cooptés oui je l' ai
toujours pensé
et
lorsque j'ai vu depardieu qui l'a bien
interprété aussi d'avoir je vais déjà
beaucoup depardieu
voyez il ya bien des questions à se
poser sur lui aussi enfin personne
larves et en croisant son immense talent
et la politique c'est aussi du temps là
où malheureusement il n'y en a plus du
tout il n'y a que des afficheurs de
chiffres qui ne soit jamais les limbes
oui j'ai passé au cyrano de bergerac
ça je n'y suis pour rien il paraît que
le nez très dit
d'une photographie dans l'ensemble du
corps
une archive que nous montrons à tous les
candidats celle de l' alerte verte
archives de la campagne présidentielle
de 74 avait alors 18 ans quand un
candidat
iconoclaste lui aussi sonne alarme et
vous savez ce qui va se passer eh bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle moquera à lundi je vous
dis au revoir et j'espère vous revoir
pour vous expliquer notre projet global
d'avenir merci mes amis tôt
rené dumont premier candidat écologiste
à l'élection présidentielle
vous en avez le souvenir jean lassalle
parfaitement et je trouve que c'est une
des images cultes de l'ina si j'ai vu et
revu à plusieurs reprises
permettez moi de me distinguer toutefois
un peu de lui parce que bien sûr je je
je je vois son caractère visionnaire
mais je n'ai jamais eu par rapport à ça
un caractère aussi
définitif est désespérée peut-être parce
que j'avais lu la bible comme j'ai lu le
capital ou
et dans la bible
est un passage où il est question du
grenelle et le guen là ça veut dire la
bande verte à l'anglais joe cole qui
n'ai jamais fais engueuler mais plutôt
l'espagnol qu'on vous l'avez rappelé il
semblerait que le guen l'un s'était pas
que là était une bande ou des cavaliers
se déplacer à bride abattue dans des
nuages de poussière je trouve que
aujourd'hui on manque peut être un peu
trop de climatologues j'en ai suivi un
certain nombre pour démontrer que sur
des périodes courtes les climats en
beaucoup le climat a beaucoup changé
mais moins au lieu de me suicider ou de
m tel père tel stress dans la vie
demande déjà assez
préoccupés par tous je préférerais qu'on
met 1 5% à la recherche fondamentale et
recherche appliquée pour trouver au plus
vite l'énergie de demain je crois
qu'elle sera solaire comme le forum
comme le laboratoire de forum à
perpignan ou alors l'énergie des marées
mélenchon qui est le candidat le plus
expérimenté avec moi en parle lui aussi
vous imaginez que nous allons 11
millions de kilomètres carrés grâce
à nos cotes
la chine ne fait que 8 millions de
kilomètres carrés est ce que vous voyez
l'espace que nous avons pour essayer de
voir ce fait pas quelque chose entre
avec la différence thermique qu'il
existe entre la surface des flots et
celle qui lie à 2000 mètres de saut je
veux que la france se dote et soit la
première à trouver l'énergie de demain
totalement renouvalables si je vous ai
bien entendu jean lassalle vous vous
contester l'idée que la terre se
réchauffe sous l'effet des activités
humaines en tout cas vous partager
l'idée qu'il y a des des cycles de
réchauffement et de refroidissement qui
sont indépendants de de l'activité
humaine sans la terre
écoutez je ne peux pas contester parce
que je ne suis pas assez
je vois un chevronné en la matière pour
ça il y à doc à décines et les images
que vous montrez le je suis président
des populations des montagnes du monde
je vois à travers les montagnes
effectivement ne siègent que les glacis
mais bien d'autres choses changer mais
en tout cas si tel est le cas on se
trompe totalement d'adressent en
accusant les hommes et les femmes sont
obligées de se servir de leurs moteurs
diesel dans leurs campagnes parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix nous avons beaucoup
parlé nous avons beaucoup
sauter comme des cabris sur nos chaises
qu'on disait le général sur l'énergie
mais qu'avons nous fait rien en tout cas
si la planète à
bouger c'est plus tôt sous l'effet des
salopards y ont
construit des bénéfices monstrueux avec
des actions qui ne respectent rien et je
ne suis pas sûr que le fait d'organiser
dans les championnats du monde de
football au qatar soit la meilleure
manière avec deux stades entièrement
construit sur les flots six autres il
faudra climatisé de montrer que nous
sommes sur la voie
du rachat
au bout de notre voyage dans les
archives de l'ina jean va ça me lie à
une rencontre
[Musique]
rencontre avec un personnage que vous
avez peut-être connu ou lui il s'agit de
frédéric dard le père de san antonio en
est l'invité du journal télévisé
d'antenne 2 nous sommes en 80 et il
parle des hommes politiques
frédéric dard est ce que vous vous
intéressez à la politique en général ou
est-ce que vous êtes tellement absorbé
par vos livres que vous vous y
intéressez pas annonce d'abord je
considère qu'à notre époque il est
possible de se désintéresser de la
politique mais ce que je trouve
regrettable c'est que la politique se
soit transformée justement par l'intérêt
qu'elles provoquent en une espèce de
spectacle
je trouve que la plupart enfin des
hommes politiques se conduisent comme
des espèces de saltimbanques la
politique spectacle dénoncez pas
frédéric dard et et ses personnages
saltimbanques vous partagez le jean
lassalle
particules après avoir reconnu vous être
livré à adé face ici à des performances
des coups d'éclat sa patte et quand même
d'avoir ces thèmes au vent parce que
j'ai vu
frédéric dard ce jour là je m'en
souviens comme si j'étais je me souviens
je ne suis pas livré à des facéties j'ai
posé des actes qui
étaient des actes graves parfois
douloureux mais je considère qu'on n'est
pas obligé de le faire en pleurant ni en
se lamentant soi même
je n'ai pas vu ghamdi pleuré lorsqu'il a
mené son peuple à bord de la mer pour le
sel je n'ai pas vu pleurer nelson
mandela qui sont des hommes pour qui
j'éprouve et à certains intérêts
socrates aurélie et 400 avant pelatan ce
délire avant athènes qui ne durera pas
longtemps celui qui est capable de faire
rire un peu aussi faire pleurer
aujourd'hui j'en trouve beaucoup plus
avait ajouté
la réciproque est rarement vraie écoute
et aujourd'hui j'en trouve beaucoup plus
qui me ferait pleurer j'en ai très peu
qui me font sourire et c'est dommage
parce que au fond l'humour fait aussi
partie de l'arsenal dont devraient
disposer un homme politique qui devrais
je le répète une fois de plus être un
artiste au terme de cet adn dans la
salle y at il un morceau essentiel de
votre adn que nous avons manqué or il
n'y en a vraiment pas beaucoup et je
dois dire pourtant je le dis pas
facilement vous savez patrick huot m
vraiment j'étais bouleversé parce
qu'elle cultive âge et j'ignorais que
vous aviez notamment les premières
mais vous savez quand on est jeune et
qu'on rêve
convient qu'on voit à la télé n'était
pas encore à la maison et qu'il ya des
événements planétaires je me souviens
d'une coupe du monde de football qui ne
devait pas avoir lieu là mais qui
finalement a eu lieu au mexique jeu
remportée par la plus grande équipe de
football je crois de tous les temps
l'équipe du brésil voyait ça je passais
par jour là vient du brésil avec les
fameux pelé rivelino
tostao jackson y sommes et autres et qui
pulvérise à un final l'italie quatre
heures et je crois me souvenir que le
commentateur et est maintenant l'un de
ceux que j'ai le plus apprécié qu'on a
connus par la suite c'était michel
drucker c'est pour montrer ma rhéto à ce
qui pourrait me voir face à ce
formidable reflet de nous même de
l'humanité de la sinisation une certaine
idée de la phrase que constitue
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel li
na qui me fait l'honneur d'inviter
aujourd'hui que j'ai éventuellement pu
m'intéresser à autre chose qu'aux
brevets à la politique ou aux fesses des
femmes
merci merci à jean lassalle raid merci
[Musique]